la préfecture a ainsi enregistré quatre
listes de candidats à l'élection des
membres de la chambre d'agriculture de
la martinique
cette année une liste présentée par la
fdsea avec à sa tête louis félix
floriane qui a fait équipe jusqu'à
maintenant avec le président sortant et
la liste justement de louis daniel
berten sans étiquette avec un peu plus
de 50 % de professionnels et chefs
d'exploitation et assimilés qui font
acte de candidature pour la première
fois l'opam confédération paysanne est
également représenté avec olivier palcy
éleveurs de petits ruminants et enfin la
quatrième liste présentée par la
coordination rurale de la martinique
avec gérald guito il veut également
quatre listes dix collèges la campagne a
d'ores et déjà commencé
une élection prévue sur plusieurs jours
de 14 au 31 janvier 2019